all righty Democrats gain in the generic
ballot amid talk of socialism the
government comes after religious
Americans again and the media
demonstrate how they drive Americans to
the right we are live in Dallas I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
well let's get into it self lot to get
to here today a lot of gets it allowed
to get to tonight you know President
Trump is trolling the left again we'll
get to that we also get to Andrew Cuomo
who's an idiot first first first I'd
like to remind yellow this is Texas come
on everybody loves their second
Amendment rights and if you are a gun if
you are a gun lover then you need to
enter to win your brand-new gun from the
USC CA if not what are your waiting for
you're about to miss the deadline the
gun today giveaway ends very soon you
could get up to 17 chances to win your
gun daily but only if you act right now
to be 17 Kimber 17 Glock 17 cigs or even
17 a ar-15s head over to defend your
family now calm reveal which gun you
could be taking home today but hurry the
free guns aren't going to last for long
today's gun disappears at midnight
tonight the US CCI wants to get more
guns into the hands of responsibly armed
Americans like you because the left will
try to take away your gun rights the
u.s. ECA will fight back they are here
to help train and protect the protector
so don't put it off don't miss your
chance because you could win a new gun
every single day just go to defend your
family now calm to enter right now again
you only have until midnight tonight to
win today's gun go to defend your family
now calm that is defend your family now
calm USC CA does wonderful work
educating people who want to carry guns
legally and in law-abiding fashion
making the country a safer place go
check them out right now and defend your
family now calm again that is defend
your family now calm okay so the
Democrats have decided on their program
for the next election cycle and the
program for the next election cycle goes
something like this
socialism plus race talk plus getting up
in our grill that is the basic idea of
the Democratic platform comet 2018 and
come 2020 and right now and president
Trump I think actually has this
relatively well pag in his own in his
own peculiar fashion the president
tweeted out this today it's pretty
spectacular the president we had happy
birthday to the leader of the Democrat
Party
Maxine Waters and I will admit the
President of the United States is a
master troll I mean he is just fantastic
controlling folks clearly he is ready to
troll Maxine Waters but what he says has
a ring of truth to it the Democratic
Party is no longer the party of even
Chuck Schumer the Democratic Party is
now the party of people like Maxine
Waters and the party of people like
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez in the party of
Bernie Sanders and the key to this whole
philosophy the key to the whole left
philosophy is that America is not that
wonderful America is not that great so
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
who's in a running gun battle with his
brother Chris Chris for stupidest Cuomo
in America I will get two prints a
little bit later on Andrew Cuomo did a
speech I believe his last night it was
released today in which he suggested
that he has a certain perspective on
America here is what Andrew Cuomo the
block of wood that runs New York had to
say about the United States we're not
going to make America great again it was
over that great
we have not reached greatness we will
reach greatness when every American is
fully engaged we will reach greatness
when discrimination and stereotyping
against women 51% of our population is
gone and every woman's full potential is
realized and unleashed and every woman
is making her full contribution when
that happens this nation is going to be
taken even that is one of the stupidest
things I have ever heard and we are all
stupider for having heard it
so even Andrew Cuomo was was bright
enough to realize that this was not a
smart thing to say so his office
clarified they released a statement
after he said this and here was their
statement Governor Cuomo disagrees with
the president the governor believes
America is great and that her full
greatness will be fully realized when
every man woman and child has full
equality America has not yet reached its
maximum potential so in other words what
he meant when he said America was not
great and has never been great is that
America is great but is not great enough
which I know about you guys that's what
I heard
right that's what I when I first heard
that I was like of course he means
America is great now the truth is that
the reason that he has to say this is
because he's running against Cynthia
Nixon this is not a minority viewpoints
in the Democratic Party it's a growing
viewpoints inside the Democratic Party
that America is a bad place now in order
for you to come up with the idea that
America is a bad place you have to be
comparing America to something that
doesn't exist
and when when you listen to what Cuomo
says right there he basically makes that
clear what he says is we have to live in
a country where 51% of the population is
is treated with utter respect and there
is no crime and everything is wonderful
and everybody loves each other and
unicorns poop rainbows and everything is
just as utopian as it could possibly be
well if that is your vision of what
America has to be in order for you to
say that America is great or was great
then America will never be great because
that's something you can never reach
it's very easy to say that something if
you're comparing your wife to a model
who's not even a real person who ages
right at some sort of virtual model
then your wife is never going to be that
okay if you're comparing America to
something that is never going to exist
it's very easy to say America was never
great now of course America was great of
course America is great it is the
greatest force for bringing people all
around the world and poverty in history
America
more than anything is great not because
it is financially powerful or militarily
powerful although I think you can argue
that there are hundreds of millions of
people around the world not living in
poverty and not living under tyranny who
would thank us for being that powerful
the reason that America really is great
is because we are founded on the
greatest idea in the history of humanity
when it comes to government and that is
the idea of god-given rights protected
by limited government right that's what
makes America fantastic correct it's the
liberty and freedom that America
represents that the left hates though
right that's the part that they don't
actually like and what Chris Cuomo is
doing here is he's trying to head off at
the past Cynthia Nixon so Cynthia Nixon
you don't remember from being the least
likable member of the Sex in the City
crew which is saying a lot and she is
running against him and she is a
full-fledged hardcore socialist she was
at Netroots a couple of weeks ago and
she said listen if they're gonna call us
all socialists we may as well be
socialists and Cuomo needs to cut her
off at the pass Rachel probably went
thirty percent of the primary vote
against Chris Paul against Andrew Cuomo
and therefore he needs to move to the
left to cut her off
what's happening is a reached a Reese
entering of the Democratic Party there's
a lot of talk in the last couple of
weeks if you've watched any of the
election analysis about how this whole
socialist upswing it's being exaggerated
inside the Democratic Party Nate Silver
tweeted out that eighty-nine percent of
all the candidates won primaries are
mainstream Democrats not socialists but
that's not really the question the
question is our mainstream Democrats now
embracing the tenets of socialism in
order to prevent socialists from
drinking their milk shake and that's
what's happening with Cuomo Cuomo is
moving to the left specifically in order
to prevent Cynthia Nixon and people like
Cynthia Nixon from drinking his
milkshake and you can see this growing
inside the Democratic Party there's a
Gallup poll that came out in the last
couple of days and it showed that a
majority of Democrats no longer hold a
positive view of capitalism nearly 60%
of Democrats feel good about socialism
now you know holds a positive view of
capitalism
who does not hold a positive view of
capitalism but feels really good about
socialism somebody who spent their
entire life living under capitalism and
no time living under socialism now in a
second we're going to talk about what
the Left says about socialism and why
it's actually not only incorrect it is
factually it's just a lie well what they
say about socialism what they believe
socialism is is what socialism is not
when you hear folks on the left say
Norway is a socialist country Norway is
not a socialist country Norway is a
capitalist country with some socialist
welfare state policies the economy of
Norway is run as a capitalist density
even the state-owned enterprises are run
in profit-seeking fashion
okay the basis of the democratic
socialists of America it's in their
platform is that profit is to be issued
you're not supposed to have profit
profits bad
so even Norway says that's not correct
but the Democrats have sort of shifted
the definition of socialism to make it
warm and fuzzy and Nordic when in
reality that's not actually what's
happening at all so the pollster
Democrats are moving in the direction of
socialism and what you see when you
actually dig down into this is the
Democrats don't even know what socialism
is they don't even know what they were
talking about perfect example of this is
the Vermont Democratic gubernatorial
candidates who Christine Hellqvist who
happens to be a transgender woman which
means that he is a biological man who
believes that he's a woman and Christine
Alquist
was on CNN talking about his program for
Vermont I used his again the reason I
say this is because I use pronouns based
on biology not based on what you think
you are
Christina Hal Quest is being quizzed by
CNN about his perspective on the the
economy and here is what Christine Hal
quest has to say it's pretty amazing
more Democrats viewed socialism
favorably than capitalism but when faced
with a choice between the two it does
sound like you look more favorably again
labels you have an issue with on the
ideas behind socialism well and yes and
I I'm not sure I even know what
socialism is so so so I just don't have
the background to answer that question I
don't know what socialism is but I am
one
I mean there are some other things that
this person thinks they are but they
don't understand the definition of if
you can't describe socialism then you
are not a socialist I think that is fair
to say and if you are living in Vermont
it's easy to get away with this sort of
thing because you are living in Vermont
it is not quite as easy to get away with
this sort of thing when you are living
in Cuba or Venezuela which are
significantly more socialist in terms of
issuing the profit motive the
nationalizing all resources then is then
is Vermont but this is indicative of the
left embrace of the language of the hard
left
without actually embracing anything
remotely resembling the actual concepts
that they say they are embracing right
it's a lie that is being told and of
course the chief purveyor of this lie
that the the new ideological thought
leader of the Democratic Party
shockingly enough is of course Bernie
Sanders so Bernie Sanders has become the
font of wisdom in the Democratic Party
which is a pretty incredible rise from a
guy who was kicked out of a comm unit
work back in the 1970s when you imagine
a guy who who had to run as an
independent because the Democrats didn't
even want him on their team really and
now he is the leader of the Democratic
Party it shows how radical the Democrats
had become I'm gonna show you some tape
of our good friend Bernie Sanders in
just a second but first let's talk about
your sleeve quality so you're not
getting enough sleep we all know it
you're not getting enough sleep and that
is why you need to try out
helix-loop-helix sleep has built a sleep
quiz indeed it takes two minutes to
complete that sleep quiz and they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to that perfect
mattress whether you are a side sleeper
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there is no more
guessing or confusion all you have to do
is go to helix sleep comm slash Ben you
take that two minutes sleep quiz and
they will match you to a mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life for couples helix could even split
that mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they even have
a 10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free so
what are you waiting for go on your
phone right now and go get a helix sleep
mattress right now he had 125 bucks off
right we love our discounts right now
hilux is offering up to 125 dollars off
all mattress orders again that's 125
bucks off at helix sleep comm / Ben that
is helix sleep comm / Ben for 125 bucks
off it's a great mattress
everybody loves helix sleep come on so
go check it out right now
okay so Bernie Sanders is the
ideological thought leader of the
Democratic Party he is the wise man upon
the mountain who sits there conveying
his genius to the rest of the American
public and he was yeah he he's stupid I
mean but Bernie Santa is I run out of
accolades for Bernie Sanders he was on
CBS this morning discussing why America
is fundamentally immoral and wrong and
this links up with the Andrew Cuomo
perspective that America is inherently
bad what MIT what would make America
better is if America were no longer
America if America were to embrace all
of these other programs and policies
that America has historically not
embraced because we believe in
individual liberty over collective
redistribution that's the basic idea so
Bernie Sanders is on with CBS this
morning and he explains why America is
fundamentally immoral it's fundamentally
immoral and it is fundamentally wrong
and I would like my pudding cup please
before I kill over my blood sugar is
simply too low I cannot handle this any
longer please play the clip I think that
there is growing resentment not only
among young people who in many cases are
gonna have a lower standard of living
than their parents I think that there is
an understanding or something
fundamentally immoral and wrong that a
nation which we have three people own
more wealth than the bottom half of the
American people that does not make sense
one of the things that you have to love
about Bernie Sanders is that his take on
economics is so disconnected from the
reality of economics the only thing I
can think to analogize it to is the use
of his hands - what he's saying right
there they're completely disconnected
and you just say he's sitting there and
he's talking to you and you don't know
what he is doing with his hands but it
just seems like at the end he's going to
be doing the Macarena no one understands
why no one understands why but what's
really great about Bernie is what Bernie
does is he says there are problems in
life and these problems are bad problems
and that means socialism
say so okay there are three rich people
and a lot of poor people unless you can
show me that the rich people stole from
the poor people I don't know what Bernie
Sanders his problem is Bernie I don't
begrudge Bernie Sanders his lake house
other than I paid for it because I'm a
taxpayer but if he'd actually worked in
private industry and bought a lake house
then I certainly don't begrudge him his
lake house Bernie Sanders his entire
priority is pointing out inequalities
that are endemic to the human condition
every society has inequality the
question is not the inequality the
question is how are poor people in the
United States living and the answer is
poor people in the United States live
better than poor people at any time in
any place in human history and it's not
particularly close and that is not to
say that's not to say that we can't have
community programs that are designed to
help poor people it doesn't mean that
there isn't endemic corruption to the
American government the benefits some at
the expense of others what it does mean
is that for him to sit there and suggest
that income inequality is indicative of
America being immoral is to ignore all
of human history as well as any context
and that's a serious problem for Bernie
Sanders in this entire perspective now
the good news for Bernie Sanders if the
media will never ask him about any of
this and I want to show you the evidence
of this so CBS is bianna golodryga she
was interviewing Bernie and they reached
the end of the interview and he's gone
through you know 15 minutes of interview
and when they reached the end of the
interview she finally says she's about
to ask him how he's going to pay for any
of this and then shockingly they run out
of time I just it's unbelievable they
just run out it's amazing watch of
course the response from many as we like
the idea is how do we pay for them this
conversation of course will continue but
we've run out of time senator oh what a
pity
oh now it's funny how the conversation
always runs out of time at just that
point in the conversation right
Alexandre Ocasio cortes listen when I
offered to either debate her or have her
on the show I wasn't doing so
I wasn't doing so because I am just in
love with the idea of spending time with
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez I'm doing so
because I would like for someone to
actually ask her a series of questions
about how she intends to pay for things
because what happens is she goes on left
shows and the media and they say things
like well how are you gonna pay for then
she says well the Republicans never pay
for anything it's like well that's kind
of true but how are you going to pay for
I don't know the quadrupling of federal
spending that you are now proposing and
then they run out of time and it's
highly highly irritating but that's the
good news for Democrats all they have to
do is go out and complain about how the
world is and then they can pose
solutions that have no relation to
reality by the way this is a terrible
recipe for life just for every
individual in the audience leading a
successful life is about recognizing the
realities of the world and then dealing
with those realities as they are the
people of the hardest time in life
whether it's in relationships or whether
it is in economics those people are
people who refuse to recognize the
realities on the ground instead they
rebel against the realities it shouldn't
be this way it shouldn't be this way
well there's certain things that
shouldn't be because it's an act of
oppression
the American Revolution happened because
there are certain things that shouldn't
be this way and that we could change but
there are a lot of things about how
human beings operate that are not
changeable right the fact is that there
are certain people who are going to be
smarter than others as I know well there
certain people are going to be taller
than others right there are lots of
there lots of discrepancies and
disparities in life accepting those
discrepancies and disparities and then
trying to deal with those not on a
collective level but by working within
the rules is the way you have a
successful society complaining and
yelling at the moon is the way you have
an unsuccessful society and a society in
which we tear each other apart and tear
each other down but that is I think what
but that I think is what so many
Democrats and members of the media wants
at this point is to separate us and tear
us down which is which brings us to the
second prong of the democratic program
and that second prong is of course the
race issue right so we've already heard
that there first prong is a bunch of
free crap and they won't say how to pay
for it and America is terrible that's
prong number one and then there is prong
number two and prong number two is
everybody I disagree with is a racist
now the best example that I could find
today this is really an astonishing
example so if you followed the news at
all today what you saw was that John
Brennan who's the former CIA director
under Barack Obama had his security
clearance revoked
by President Ronald
and frankly I think rightly so I don't
even understand the policy where your
security clearance operates beyond your
actual working for the government it
doesn't make any sense to me if you want
to contract with the government for
anybody right this is not a partisan
issue
it seems to me weird they are out of
government but somebody can come spill
classified secrets to you and it's
totally okay because you still have your
security clearance with Brennan it's a
particular issue because Brennan is a an
extraordinarily politically active
Democrat he was even when he was at the
CIA
Kimberley's wrassle over at The Wall
Street Journal had a piece back in July
in which she detailed exactly how it was
that brendan was basically feeding
information to Harry Reid in order to
have Harry Reid come out and suggest
that there was Russian collusion between
Russia and and then candidate Donald
Trump's trowel talked about that at the
time so revoking Brennan's security
clearance it seems to me like kind of a
no-brainer honestly and the and the
White House explained why exactly they
did it they said mr. Brennan's lying and
recent conduct characterized by
increasingly frenzied commentary is
wholly inconsistent with access to the
nation's most closely held secrets and
facilitates the aim of our adversaries
which is to sow division and chaos now
it seems to me what they really should
just say is that Brennan doesn't work
with the government anymore he doesn't
need a security clearance it's a little
bit weird to have this particular
president talking about like frenzied
commentary and eccentric conduct and
behavior as a rationale for not seeing
secret information I mean it he's the
president he's elected Brennan is not
elected so he has the ability to say
that fine but the part of this that's
really weird is what the Democrats
actually had to say about this what the
left is saying about this because what
what you're about to hear is that there
are people on the Left who believe that
the Brennan thing has to do with racism
Brennan if you hadn't noticed is not a
person of color right Brennan is whiter
than the backside of this piece of paper
but it has to do with racism I'll
explain in just a minute but first let's
talk about 23andme it's a DNA testing
service that ought to be used on
Elizabeth Warren at the first available
opportunity
not without her permission of course we
wouldn't want anything like that but she
should take a 23andme ancestry quiz
because I think that she owes it to
herself really not see not even house to
herself to know about her Cherokee roots
where those high cheekbones came from
the 23andme health and ancestry service
includes reports on how DNA can
influence your weight sleep quality
caffeine intake sense of taste whether
you're likely to be lactose intolerant
as more and more it's very easy to do
all you have to do is spit into a tube
provided in that 23andme kit and then
mail that saliva back to the lab to be
analyzed and then give you all sorts of
information about yourself including
your ancestry so if you ever decide to
apply for a professorship at Harvard Law
School under some minority guys I'm just
speculating here then it would be good
to have this sort of information lying
around okay order your 23andme health an
ancestry service kit right now at
23andme comm slash there really is a lot
of fun I've tried it myself go check it
out 23andme comm slash career that's two
three and me.com slash Shapiro go check
it out right now so what is so racist
about the firing or the removal of
security clearance from John Brennan no
one knows but the Huffington Post knows
so this is what the Huffington Post so
it wasn't just John Brennan the White
House is now talking about removing
security clearances from a lot of people
a lot of people they're talking about
removing it from James clapper and James
Comey who doesn't even have a security
clearance anymore Michael Hayden who
doesn't have a security clearance
anymore Sally Yates Susan Rice Andrew
McCabe Peter struck Lisa Paige and Bruce
or all those people they want to remove
security clearances from sounds fine to
me
now well is it good politics to remove
it from people who criticize you it's
not smart politics but it would be good
if we just had a blanket rule again that
if you're not employed with the
government your security clearance goes
away and that's the end of the story but
here is how the Huffington Post plays
this I kid you not this is their lead
headline over at The Huffington Post
criticized for racism Trump goes after
black former national security adviser
who are we talking about Susan Rice so I
just named to you let's see we can count
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten people one of those people is
black they pick out the one person who's
black he's talking about and they say
that the entire thing is racist
this is how far the left is willing to
stretch in order to accuse the president
of racism this is of course is why they
are so overjoyed about Omarosa Manigault
who suddenly is earning a strange new
respect from the left the way that they
called a liar and whatever the female
version of an Uncle Tom is now she's
earned strange new respect from the left
I mean that seriously there's an article
in the Chicago Tribune today to column
it is by woman named Darlene Glanton and
here is the column title Omarosa may
have earned back her black card
see better guy guys guys that's not
racist that's not racist this is your
that's not racist it's racist to take
John to take away John Brennan's
security clearance that's racism that's
true
vicious Bull Connor racism but saying
that I'm Rosa Manigault just got back
her black card cuz she criticized Trump
that's not racism at all that's just
that's just spicy talk all right so I
mean the reason I say that is because
literally this was the argument that was
made a week and a half ago about Sarah
Zhang and
over the New York Times they said that
that's just how people of color talk
about white people and you have to
understand that's not racism it's just
how people talk right means just kind of
spicy talk that you use in any case here
is the column
come on african-americans have a heart
Omarosa Manigault Newman desperately
wants her black card back I think we
ought to consider giving it to her look
I know we can't take this exclusive
membership card awarded to every black
person at Birth for granted it takes a
lot to get it taken away and it's only
fitting that black people have to jump
through a lot of Hoops to get it back
maybe Omarosa deserves a second chance
Omarosa scarred was put in jeopardy when
she says shade onto the stage at a
Donald Trump campaign rally in Ohio two
years ago and criticized Barack Obama
for trying to sell us hope
african-americans collectively snatched
her card away when she took a job in
Trump's White House is this the thing
that is this like is how it works I'm
pretty sure not I'm like where is it
there an actual card is there a crew of
people who go to your house do they
remove the card from you do they revoke
it over the phone like a credit card
just go to a credit agency do you if
you're really good at being black do you
get like a black black card or like or
like a platinum black card if you're
really extraordinary according to this
columnist
now that Omarosa is promoting a new
tell-all Brooke she's practically on her
knees begging for black people's
forgiveness and she has come bearing
gifts okay so now that now she's
criticizing Trump this means she's
legitimately black again so this column
concludes she's given African Americans
yet another example of what happens
every time one of us tries to give Trump
a chance she has forced Trump to reveal
on Twitter has dealt one right disdain
for African American women she has
challenged black people not only to
think smart but act smart especially in
these troubled times black heart or not
Omarosa is still one of ours she has
nowhere else to go so tolerant nothing
but town
nothing but tolerance from what but
don't worry they are out there fighting
president Trump's vicious brutal racism
I also appreciate that that everything
about Omarosa like Trump criticizing
Omarosa is now racist when they were
criticizing her his associate path and a
liar five minutes ago
then it wasn't racist but now Trump is a
racist so Seth Meyers says that Trump is
a racist with a rotted out soul this is
this is real comedy styling from Seth
Meyers regular late-night comedians
really just showing their comedic chops
night in and night out here at Seth
Meyers making you laugh with your mind
not with your mouth we had our fun here
but in regards this Omarosa business
let's not forget that anyone calls a
black woman a dog is a racist with a
rotted out soul okay and that's when the
clapper comes writes out laughter it's
clap truss where the entire audience
awkwardly claps and then we say oh it's
a new kind of comedy a comedy without
laughter it's so deep it's so great
now how Democrats hope to win with this
message that Trump is a racist and by
extension everybody else is a racist and
they're making that argument explicit
like Charles blow over the New York
Times he says that if the if the the
aptly-named is Charles Charles blow at
the New York Times he says if the Trump
n-word tape is real amuro's has been
going around peddling this idea that
there is a tape of President Trump
saying the n-word so far we have seen
zero evidence of this I'm
extraordinarily skeptical of this claim
because he's been president for a year
and a half he ran a highly contentious
race we got tape of him talking about
grabbing women by the genitals you
figure if that one's out there probably
somebody would've paid for by this point
but Charles Bois says if that tape
surfaces it would increase his support
because everybody in this room everybody
on the right secretly loves the n-word
even though I've never used the n-word
in my life and hate the n-word and I've
said openly that I think that if
President Trump is caught using the
n-word disparagingly on tape it might be
time for a primary challenge even people
like me I would actually be celebrating
if the n-word tape Israel's where
Charles blow has to say I think that if
you found the tape of him using the
n-word and it might actually increase
his support among the people who support
him this is this does nothing to them
they are so baked in they believe
wholeheartedly in this approach that he
is taking the castigation of an entire
half of the country as racist sexist
bigoted in a homophobic didn't work for
Hillary Clinton but they're going to
double down on that and they're going to
combine it with Bernie Sanders and
socialism and hope that this somehow
achieves electoral victory now maybe
it'll work but only only if the right is
so toxic then it drives the middle away
because the fact is left is so toxic it
is driving the middle away it should be
driving the middle way their program is
to control their program is to condemn
their program is to suggest that anyone
who disagrees with them is somehow
morally bankrupt the New York Times has
an amazing piece it just came out
tonight going after me personally which
is always fun it's always a badge of
honor when the New York Times comes
after you because I don't know I
describe it except to say like every so
often my two and a half year old son
just randomly decides to charge me and
attack me and it's really cute and it's
really fun and I let him pretend to
knock me over and the whole deal except
he's cute and he's two and a half years
old the New York Times has about the
same impact except it's the world's most
famous newspaper so they have a column
Tom of the New York Times by a woman
named Ginny uh Belafonte and the column
is titled ignore condescend dismiss
debate playbook for men facing women
name I think that's a really weird title
for a column talking about how I
challenged a woman to discuss issues
with me did I ignore did I condescend
did I dismiss I asked her I offered to
pay money to a charity of her choice or
to her campaign to talk with me but this
is somehow ignoring condescending or
dismissing her pretty amazing I'm gonna
go through all of that in just a second
first I have to remind you that if you
are listening to this then you ought to
go over to Daley wire.com right now and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get your
subscription to daily wire con anything
to get my show it means you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the execrable
Michael Knowles show I hope they're
keeping him in the jail beneath this
facility and you also when you spend $99
earring at that annual subscription you
get this the very greatest in that all
beverage vessels
feel the magnificence emanating from it
you are in the presence of the vessel
the leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
you get that with the annual
subscription also we have a Sunday
special every Sunday when you subscribe
at YouTube or iTunes you get that as
well and that means that you get to see
greg gutfeld he's coming on sunday which
is gonna be blast so go check that out
right now we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the New York Times is busily
castigating everybody on the right side
of the aisle you have them in
castigating everybody is racist and now
you're castigated is sexist if you ask a
Democrat to talk about issues so this
column in the New York Times says last
week ben shapiro the right-wing pundit
elicited outrage on his behalf from
conservatives when he asked the
Democratic congressional candidate
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez to debate him
and said she did not and she said she
did not or responds to unsolicited
requests from men with bad intentions
right that drew outrage because what I'm
legitimately what thing about that
response that I found so humorous legit
when I first saw that pop up on my
Twitter feed I actually started laughing
out loud it is so funny what's funny
about that is that they're about five
different responses that would have
sufficed she could just said yeah or she
could have just said you know what
you're not running against me not all
that interested but thanks you have done
a dozen different ways but instead she
got together with a room of her top
advisers and decided to suggest that I
was cat calling her by asking for a
debate now you may notice as a member
and charter member of ben shapiro in the
texas Jewboys i am not well known for my
cat calling abilities I tried it on my
wife recently and it did not go great
and apparently cat but apparently I've
just been doing it wrong all these years
if I just started challenging women on
the street to debate it would have been
amazing when I was in college I would
just stood on the street coming like hey
baby let's talk to me Kahn
how about we redistribute some of those
assets what do you think what in the
what in the world so she suggested that
I was cat calling her and then the New
York Times suggests that I was somehow
doing something deeply wrong this is
what they say Ms Ocasio Cortez is under
no obligation to debate someone who is
not running for anything she does find
herself however in the comparatively
unusual position of igniting the
interests of men who want to argue with
her whatever their motives well I think
it has more to do with the fact that
you've declared her the face of the
Democratic Party then that I just feel
like talking to a former bartender from
New York I barely have friends to talk
to let alone random bartenders from New
York why would I possibly do that it was
so funny somebody from the New York
Times actually called me up about this
story and they said so do you think
those sexist to offer $10,000 to talk to
Alexander Oh Cosmo Cortez no I get
50,000 to talk to Bernie right on the
phone are you kidding but the idea here
is of course that if you try to talk
with the left you are sexist and racist
if you don't try to talk with the left
you are sexist in a racist no matter
what you do you are a sexist in a racist
and then they wonder why people are
running screaming from them and then the
screaming is going to become even louder
because this is just an astonishing case
that broke yesterday it's it's really an
amazing thing and that is this case
having to do with masterpiece cake shop
so the government is coming up to
masterpiece cake shop again it's a
masterpiece cake shop in case you didn't
recall is a religious Baker
he lives in Colorado his name is Jack
Phillips and he declined to bake a cake
for a same-sex wedding and the this one
all the way up to the Supreme Court
because the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission decided to find him in noir
Dannette amounts of money because he
would not bake a cake for a lesbian
wedding because he is a Christian Baker
which is his rights in the United States
of America so this goes all the way up
to the Supreme Court
this goes all the way to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court issues a
very narrow ruling in which they say
that you're not allowed to tell a
religious Baker that he must bake a
same-sex wedding cake unless you're
really nice about it that's really what
that ruling says now for people who are
celebrating the ruling the ruling
basically said that this the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission was mean about
it and condescending about it and that's
why it was unconstitutional but if they
had just said you have to bake the cake
and done in a nice fashion it would have
been okay well that gave all sorts of
ideas to folks on the left so on Tuesday
Jack Phillips filed a new lawsuit
against the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission because the Civil Rights
Commission has apparently issued a
preliminary ruling penalizing him again
this time for not making a gender
transition celebration cake which I
didn't even know was a thing I mean the
real question is is the caterers in a
pie in any case
on the same day the High Court agreed to
review the masterpiece case according to
the Daily Caller an attorney named
autumns Gardena called Philips his shop
and asked him to create a cake
celebrating a sex transition the caller
asked the cake include a blue exterior
and a pink interior a reflection of
scardino's transgender identity all
right Philips declines to create the
cake in the months that follow the
bakery received requests for cakes
featuring marijuana use sexually
explicit messages calm down that and
satanic symbols as well one solicitation
submitted by email asked the cake shop
to create a three-tiered white cake -
picking Satan licking a functional
9-inch sex toy this guy has some
creative ideas about cakes and too much
time on his hands so Philips believes
that Scardino made all these requests
and then finally decided to go to the
Civil Rights Commission and sue so the
Civil Rights Commission issued a
preliminary penalty and now he is suing
the Civil Rights Commission the left
really wants to play this game this is
the game they want to play this is the
game where they force you to believe all
the things that you don't believe and to
behave in ways that they see fit to
force you to behave if they think is a
winning formula socialism you're a
racist and you're a religious bigot and
so we're gonna force you to do
everything in our power to violate your
religion outside of your church and
probably inside of your church in pretty
short order I just don't think that that
is a solid pitch and the media are
helping out in making a non solid pitch
for Democrats honestly like Donald Trump
is very unpopular as a president just in
terms of his popularity writing his
popular particular group of people but
his overall popularity rating is not
particularly high he has a 50/50 shot at
winning reelection because the left is
this garbage and so in the New York
Times how crazy is the left this is this
is my favorite story of the day this
story is so good it's so good I saved it
for you I bring it to you
I bring it to you and I offer it in
humble obeisance for your fandom it is
just spectacular so there is a there is
a advice column there's an advice column
in the New York Times I know why would
you read it well you want their advice
for but apparently some people do so
says somebody writes a letter and he
says that his name is whitey now this
should have been the New York Times his
first clue that maybe they were getting
trolled it was not because we have now
reached the point in American politics
we are now violating what is called
Poe's law Poe's law is an internet law
that basically says that if you are not
extraordinarily clear about when you are
being facetious on the internet everyone
will take you literally that's exactly
what happened in this case here is the
advice letter dear sugars yes that's the
name of the advice columnist I'm riddled
with shame white shame this isn't
helpful to me or to anyone especially
people of color I feel like there is no
me outside of my white upper-middle
class cisgender identity I feel like my
literal existence hurts people like I'm
always taking up space that should
belong to someone else a human being
wrote this I consider myself an ally I
research proper etiquette read writers
of color vote in a way that will not
harm people of color and other
vulnerable people I engage in
conversations about privilege with other
white people boy person is a real party
I take courses that will further educate
me I donate it to black lives matter
again I fear that nothing is enough part
of my fear comes from the fact that
privilege is invisible to itself what if
I'm doing or saying insensitive things
without realizing it and then it
continues it continue there's more I
don't talk about my feelings because
it's hard to justify doing so while
people of color are dying due to
systemic racism and making this
conversation about me would be again
Center and whiteness yet bottling it up
makes me feel an existential anger then
I have a hard time channeling since I
don't know my place instead of
harnessing my privilege for greater good
I'm curled up in a ball of shame
how can I be more than my heritage
this was signed whitey but here's the
best part okay that's not even the good
part the good part is the response from
Steve Almond one of the sugars shame and
anger are powerful emotions whitey yeah
let's give these people power over a
government and yet your central struggle
is around identity you right you don't
know your place in fact your letter
describes your place as a kind of prison
cell of privilege what you really feel
is trapped within an identity that marks
you inescapably as an oppressor this
feeling is especially acute right now I
suspect because you're suddenly immersed
in a milieu there are flecks you're
privileged back to you we do live in a
culture steeped in white supremacy and
class bigotry as well as patriarchal
values this is the New York Times
writing okay so the answer is go kill
yourself basically hey their final
solution is that they say that this
person should give more money to black
lives matter of course and then buy an
extra subscription to The New York Times
and then read a lot of time he see coats
and that kind of thing and then you then
that's how you get over your white
privilege and that's how you feel better
about yourself is by reading a bunch of
people who tell you that you're a piece
of crap and you shouldn't and you really
have no place in the world that is the
best way to do this why oh why would
people resonate to Donald Trump I can't
understand it it's just a puzzlement
and then the media continue pushing the
sense I promised you that we'd do the
bookended Cuomo's so we started with
Andrew Cuomo the stupider of the Cuomo
brothers but don't worry his brother is
giving him a run for his money
Chris Cuomo over on CNN had this to say
he's again driving Trump voters back
into the arms of Trump saying we treat
Trump better than we treat our own
children because we let him get away
with everything Chris Cuomo block of
wood part two why because this kind of
ugly talk is contagious it creates a
coarseness that leads to unintelligent
confrontation you wouldn't say it at
your best you wouldn't let your kids say
it why let the president this is the man
charged with the greatest powers over
the mightiest nation and the most
updated okay so he is I love that Donald
deeply immoral you treat him better than
you treat your own children flashback
Chris Cuomo like 48 hours ago
pure Punk who comes to start trouble in
a mask and hurt people you're not about
any virtuous cause you're just somebody
who's gonna be held to the standard of
doing something wrong but when someone
comes to call out bigots and it gets hot
even physical are they equally wrong as
the bigot they are fighting I argue no
within within 72 hours calling Omarosa a
dog is bad oh great
fair okay although as I said yesterday
on the show president Trump legitimately
has called half the population of the
United States a Doug it's ready you look
like a Doug you're fired like a Doug
Kristen Stewart dumped Robert Pattinson
that could Doug okay so that is really
really terrible but encouraging people
in masks to wail on other people in the
United States and attack cops and
bottles that's kind of okay it's kind of
okay I don't know what happened when God
passed out the brains he just went right
over the Cuomo family alrighty so you
know what I think cuz I want to get to
the Q&A here let's let's do some things
I like in some things I hate let's do
things I like I I don't like this I love
this I savor this so Jason Kessler is
the worst
Jason Kessler is an actual white
supremacist he was the leader of the
unite the right rally he part one and
then unite the right part to the
pathetic revenge and he was doing an
interview with an actual Nazi via in his
basement via a via a phone the guy's
name is Patrick little and what happens
next is just delicious to the eyes and
the ears
you got a drunk roommate there
like that
clean your room I'm gonna assume that's
a parent there I'm not sure
Jason why he staying with your not
staying with the northen toxic you are
you know my father so what happened for
those who missed it is that Jason
Kessler was literally in his father's
basement and his father came to the door
and doesn't like that his son is a Nazi
and started yelling at him to stop it in
the middle of an interview about Nazism
also you I'm fairly certain this is the
first time in history that anyone has
uttered the sentence oh my god North
your thoughts Jews at the door have they
come for us historically that works the
reverse way okay time for a couple of
things that I hate
okay so hatred galore let's do this
thing so the NFL is now initiating male
cheerleaders are you excited about this
now
now the truth is that male cheerleaders
have been a thing for a long time but
they're the guys who actually pick up
the girls and like throw them in the air
and everything right they actually use
you know their superior upper-body
strength
and masculinity to perform physical
feats that's usually what they do but
that is not what the NFL is doing
anymore
the LA Rams the New Orleans Saints will
have male cheerleaders dancing on their
squads now for the first time and it is
just spectacular various of these
dancers have come out and said this is a
real change it's really great they're
gonna be doing the same dance moves as
the ladies now we have a large audience
sitting here right now question ladies
in the audience give a shout so I can't
see all you ladies in the audience okay
so I gotta lay a lot of ladies in the
audience when you watch let's say you
watch football and it so happens there
are some attractive men who play
football which team I hear some
enthusiasm for that are you more
interested in the attractive men who
play football or the men who are
performing exactly the same dance moves
as the ladies with the pom-poms yeah I'm
getting the sense that it's the football
and I know that what is definitely gonna
pull the NFL out of its rating spiral is
is a real feminization of the sport a
real openness to new aspects of gender
that we hadn't actually considered
before one day a young boy might not
just aspire to play linebacker for the
Dallas Cowboys a young boy might aspire
a young boy might as well I mean if you
want to make the playoffs well but in
any case
I'm just kidding guys I'm just kidding
[Applause]
look I'll be honest with you I can't I
got it I got it I gotta take the hits
where I can get him I'm embarrassed man
but it's okay dad Prescott's a good
quarterback it'll be fine everything's
good okay so plus he stands up for the
anthem so thumbs up on that one but it
seems to me that there are certain areas
in American life where a little bit of
teaching of sports would be good and the
masculine part of sports is a good thing
that's something I want to teach my own
son I'm not sure I want my son to play
football because I'm not big on the
brain damage but I would want my son to
play baseball I wouldn't want my son to
play and ask if I want my son to play
sports because I do think that it
inculcates not only team spirit but a
sense of responsibility sports is a
meritocracy it inculcates the idea that
you are part of a team and there's
something larger than you all of this is
good stuff now it's fun I don't care if
boys are dancing it really makes no
difference to me at all but you try and
suggest that this is what the NFL has
been lacking is just silly talk the new
audiences are going to be drawn in
because they need to watch the two guys
among the 24 hot women with bare
midriffs matter that's going to draw
that and come on come on ok so that's
the thing that I hate other things that
I hate the so Patton Oswalt was very
upset Patton Oswalt is the guy who is
most famous for playing the voice of the
rat and ratatouille he's also a is a
comedian he's been on a lot of shows
probably recognize his face from some of
these shows so he tweeted out he's very
angry at me because I challenged Ocasio
Cortez to debate so he tweeted out why
does ben shapiro want to debate
alexander Oh Cosmo Cortez he's not
running for office he should debate me
I'm also a short clown no one takes
seriously fair okay so hey kind of funny
right a minute all right
but the part of this that's weird is
that I immediately responded patton
oswalt had fine come on the sunday
special and suddenly he is gone poof
it's magic
so it turns out that as soon as you
actually offer someone the ability to
talk about the issues he I guess I'm
catcalling patton oswalt now yeah if you
could really really cut that out
okay final thing that I hate today so
this is this one's a little bit spicy we
have a few younger audiences in the
crowd so I'll try to make this pg-rated
as much as I can okay there is an
article from The Daily Mail and there's
another article in Salon Today talking
about sex robots now this has become a
new thing that's been pushed by a lot of
members of media sex robots are going to
take over the future which is going to
put mr. president calm down
I mean the hardest-hit if sex robots
take over the future hardest-hit stormy
Daniels right but the argument that is
now being made is that sex robots could
one day help failing marriages we're
going to the Daily Mail according to an
economics professor at the University of
British Columbia and who would you talk
to about relationships other than an
economics professor the futuristic
droids could improve marriages by making
husbands and wives focus more on love
and parenting instead of sexual
compatibility in a book called robot sex
social and ethical implications hot
seller professor marina ad shade claims
the advent of sex robots will change our
societal norms around marriage
particularly when it comes to monogamy
she refers to this phenomenon a sexpot
induced social change and she says
that'll be just like birth control she
says this availability will give couples
greater opportunity to define their own
types of marriages now the part of this
that's deeply troubling is the idea that
the goal of your sex life is solely
sexual pleasure and this of course has
been a cause on the left for a very very
long time the idea that you are supposed
to separate off relationships and love
from sex you're supposed to separate off
sexes role in the creation and bearing
of children from actual sexual pleasure
sexual pleasure is the be-all end-all
it's the only thing that matters and so
the natural outgrowth of that is we can
have sex with the robot but you can live
with somebody like we don't actually
want to have sex with them that is
totally cool it's a new kind of marriage
one of the things about marriage that
marriage is designed to do marriage is
designed to allow you to have sex with a
person presumably of the opposite sex
who you then produce children with and
it's designed to teach you to grow up
really that's what marriage is designed
to do is to teach you to become an adult
our site is it's really adolescent view
of what marriage is that marriage what
sex is the sex is supposed to be every
relationship you ever have it's supposed
to be like that that first time in the
back of a pickup truck when you were 17
that's that's what sex is gonna be like
your entire life and that's what sex
should always be and then a few more and
then if sex isn't like that something is
missing in your relationship because
your relationship is built around sex
and she's saying the predictable
outgrowth of that is okay well it's not
gonna be like that with your wife
because you both get older you know each
other better and there isn't that same
excitement and that's true so why not
just stuff a robot right not not go why
not go after Roby for Rosie from the
Jetsons and the answer is first of all
don't harass the help but second of all
but second of all sexual compatibility
is something that actually is built over
time okay there is the initial sexual
spark obviously but sexual compatibility
is something that grows and changes
within a marriage and sex becomes not
just a form of physical stimulus it
becomes a form of emotional bonding with
your spouse now this is why sex within
marriage is particularly important for
women because the truth is that women
have been disproportionately harmed by
the promiscuous sexual mentality of
modern society because women inherently
are built of Ellucian airily to connect
emotion with sex in a way that men
simply are not but this is what teaches
men to become men to curb their own
behavior to actually treat women like
human beings and not just sex objects
having sex confined within marriage
makes men better men it makes them
better and if they are treating with
their spouses badly if they are treating
women badly within marriage because they
have an adolescent view of sex that's
because they need to grow up and I'd
like all the dudes in the audience to
notice something most of the cheers that
are happening right now are from the
ladies in the audience because you know
what it turns out that what ladies
actually wants is not what our ariana
grande says they want in her music
videos what ladies actually want is to
get married and be married to one person
and have children for that one person
with that one person okay and to form a
partnership with that one person and to
grow and change and love for their whole
life that is what women are looking for
so if you are a good man that is what
you're looking for - so the
commercialization of sex is merely an
outgrowth of prior commercialization so
it's it's an inevitable thing that
eventually we'll get to the point where
we're having sex with inanimate objects
and then bragging to ourselves about how
we've made society a better place we
have made society an infinitely worse
place if you want to have a solid
relationship if you want to have a
better life if you want to be a better
person
right which should be your goal it
should be your Telos or Aristotelian
goal in life it should be your Tilos in
life to become a better person to use
your reason and not your genitals as
your guiding force okay if that is the
case then yes sex has a wonderful and
glorious and fun place within life but
to make it the sole goal of a
relationship or to take it outside of
relationship altogether is to rob it of
its actual importance and meaning
all right well we'll have much more to
talk about tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is produced by Senya Villarreal
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing